what's up wisecrack Helen again now that
henry cavill is off to kick some ass in
the new netflix adaptation of The
Witcher will we get one man of Steel who
knows but in the meantime if you want to
see what Superman would be like as a
sociopath then you can hop on over to
Amazon and check out its phenomenal
series the boys or as films like The
Avengers asked us to imagine how rad it
would be to have two Caped Crusader's
marauding through our cities the boys
asked us to imagine how utterly dystopic
it would be the boys gives us
superheroes who are not only celebrities
but obscenely rich with endorsements and
movie rights and while it explores many
issues like showed superheroes serve in
the military or how pervy with the
Invisible Man be perhaps no wish you was
more prevalent than domination and no
we're not talking about the whips and
gags kind of domination okay there's
some of that but no we're talking about
the philosophical sense of domination
the unfair use of power against a group
or individual so sit back strap in and
strap on your you-know-what
let's just get right into it in this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
the boys and yeah spoilers first a quick
primer the boys follows the journey of
everyman Huey who spends his days
working at an electronics shop and
living with his dad Simon Pegg the
Huey's life is turned upside down when
the world's fastest man a train
literally does a hit-and-run on his
girlfriend leaving her in a well a train
is a member of the 7 an elite Hero Squad
owned and operated by bought while
Vaught tries to pay Huey off our boy
instead opts for revenge
in doing so he teams up with Billy
butcher a not so ethical ex CIA officer
with a serious hatred for suits what
starts out as a corporate espionage job
quickly spirals out of control the team
grows they shove a bottle up a
superheros ass did you do to me he stuck
a lump of plastique up your bum son and
they eventually uncovered the terrifying
truth that one is not born but rather
becomes a superhero Samaritans embrace
led by Ezekiel but bankrolled by Vaught
has been shipping compound lead of 53
hospitals across the country since 1971
and gift-wrapping it as polio vaccine
are you telling me God's not reaching up
with pots of American girls and blessing
babies
fortunately this information isn't
enough to bring down the company
especially in light of the wave of
supervillain terrorism that's spreading
across the globe
now before we get into the Nitty Gritty
we have to lay some ground rules for
what domination philosophically speaking
entails now there's a lot of definitions
from a lot of different philosophers and
schools of thought but for this episode
we're going to talk about philosopher
Christoph McCammon s blanket definition
as he argues there are roughly five
central traits that characterize
domination and you can see each tenant
rear its ugly head throughout season one
of the boys
number one domination is a kind of power
exerted over people it can be physical
like the big kid wailing on the scrawny
kid in the playground or it can be
social like losing your job if you
snitch on your coworker we're spying on
you in the bathroom
this isn't your damn pervert or if you
say you don't like the mandalorian
number two domination involves an
imbalance of power in fact the word
domination actually comes from the Latin
word Dominus and while the particular
latin phrasing might bring to mind the
blood and boobs of the star show
Spartacus
it actually means master as in a
master/slave relationship obviously a
big source of an imbalance of power
could arise from literally shooting
death rays out of your eyes or even just
being able to pull enough strings to let
a washed-up super see his estranged
daughter number three
domination has many forms you don't have
to be beating the stuffing out of
someone to dominate them simply abusing
their trust and making them believe a
lie is enough not unlike how BOTS lead
scientists manipulated homeland or by
telling him his son was dead number four
domination is in some sense arbitrary or
unconstrained it's mostly up to the
dominating party to decide how and when
to use their powers no matter how
ridiculous you know what a king
literally kills the messenger just
because he's pissed at the bad news
yeah that's domination or when homeland
er goes against protocol to kill a
sniper who posed no threat to him also
domination you know the drill he shot at
us first
and finally number five domination is in
some way morally unjust or socially
illegitimate in other words domination
just feels wrong as if the moral or
legal rights of the dominated are
somehow trampled domination goes in
every direction in the boys characters
dominate other characters from basic
illegal imprisonment to gross abuse of
power to kidnapping your child there's
also the recurring joke of animal
domination
since the deep can communicate with sea
life he has admittedly distressed by the
lobster tank at the grocery store or the
imprisonment of his dolphin comrades and
sure we could continue about all the
people wrong by Supes but what's really
striking about the show is its focus on
systems of domination rather than just
individual acts that is the show frames
how domination occurs in a larger
framework of two particular systems hero
worship and capitalism importantly in
both instances our victims on some level
accept this domination it's called in
philosophy speak socially legitimate
domination and yeah I know that sounds a
bit like an oxymoron since by our own
definition domination is socially
illegitimate so let me explain socially
legitimate domination is still
domination it's just one that we tacitly
accept whether through our laws culture
or just our collective shrugs when
Nestle negotiates rights to bottled
water from the government while everyone
around them is in dire need of water
that's socially legitimate domination as
philosopher Michael Thompson puts it the
norms institutions and values of the
community shape the rationality of
subjects to accept forms of power and
social relations and collective goals as
legitimate forms of authority in simpler
terms
what makes domination socially
legitimate is the fact that Society
provides sun-baked and justification for
it socially legitimate domination is
power under color of right one that
victims internalize as legitimate
because society tells them so it's the
reason why that despite there being a
whole support group or victims of
superheroes they still manage to idolize
their dominators did it ever occur to
you that I split your spine or broke
your book just for a laugh basically
right so how do socially legitimate
systems dominate in the boys let's start
with wisecracks favorite dead horse
capital
while there is a lot of evil going on in
the boys perhaps nothing preoccupies the
show like the corrupting influence of
money
superheroes are not exactly upholders of
virtue and justice but costumed
influencers quibbling over revenue and
royalties we've all got wat four points
each
you got four points their services are
sold to cities to the tunes of millions
of dollars while we're thinking about
making a move how much 300 million a
year and they make just as much in
lucrative movie and merch news our
latest film g-men world war just grossed
shy of 1.7 billion dollars worldwide in
chasing their bottom line superheroes
blur the line between person and product
as a result even our heroes find
themselves being dominated forced to
throw away their values and even their
loved ones starlight is chastised for
doing a plainclothes beat down of some
would-be rapists until popular sentiment
ships allowing bot to plaster over star
lights own values with a rebrand that
sells sex under a feminist label it's
totally you it's bold its brave its
feminist how is that feminist empowering
it says you're confident in your own
skin and you're not afraid to show it
most importantly it tells the story of
your transformation of what you're going
through this is on a few of the facets
of domination power exerted over
starlight who must shut up and play nice
check an imbalance of power between her
and sanely rich employers in her check a
company that is unconstrained in their
power because they are literally in the
business of saving the world check
remember how we described socially
legitimate domination as power under
color of right the PR employees couching
their arguments and feminist terms is
exactly that an abuse of power cloaked
under the guise of being hashtag blue of
course when starlight tries to push back
the capitalist machine then drops the
pretense of benevolence either get with
it get out it's my body I have the right
to choose how much of it I show that is
true you do you just won't be doing it
in the seventh
unless it is wrapped in that what star
light experiences however is far from
unique the boys takes time to explore
how domination doesn't just affect some
permanent underclass of victims but even
those who go on to dominate others this
is because in many cases people have
accepted and internalized the status quo
as inevitable and socially legitimate
take a train the fastest man alive who
also murdered Huey's girlfriend while
smuggling drugs his whole life is
dedicated to maintaining his brand and
his spot on the seven he's unable to
disclose his relationship to a fellow
superhero simply because it would be bad
for his public image and thus bad for
business
maintaining these public facing personas
also happens to be their one weakness as
Billy butcher explains you're a smart
lad but he's still like twig one
weakness they will go
mutations but a train doesn't just find
himself living a double life he also
finds himself forced to make some pretty
awful decisions even by his low
standards for starters he chooses to
inject himself with superhero steroids
lest he lose his place on the seven and
his lucrative endorsements
you know what Stillwell told me if I
don't win I'm a help but if a life of
drugs wasn't bad enough he also decides
to dabble in murder killing pop call to
keep his involvement with compound V the
secret importantly a-train views
girlfriend murder as the only
possibility available to him in his
words it wasn't his boat boat and
believing that he has no choice in the
matter a train is experiencing what
philosopher Michael Thompson would call
constitutive domination the abused are
unwilling to attest their status because
they accept the system that creates it
and one of the shows more transparent
moments a psychotic Superman says this
they're just people but they snap their
fingers and we jump why why do we do
that cuz they sign our checks but there
are more subtle ways capitalism forces
everyone and everything to bend the knee
in the boys the best example is vod's
campaign to integrate superheroes
directly into the US Army's chain of
command thereby securing a lucrative
federal contract in vod's quest to get
Congress's approval it goes beyond the
typical corporate schmoozing that's most
important VP Madeline Stillwell go so
far as to blackmail a lead senator with
us
sex tape in another instance bot
actually deploys home Lander and Maeve
to stop a hijacking all without the
government's authorization
even after captain sociopath fries the
cockpit and dooms everyone to a watery
grave bot is able to cover up their
involvement and still pitch their case
we arrived three minutes after the plane
went down why because we're not in the
chain of command in both instances bot
is able to act outside of both the law
of the land and the law of public
opinion unduly manipulating US policy
it's socially legitimate domination not
just upon the voters but the government
institutions themselves in exercising
such arbitrary power over the government
and its people what brings to life
President Eisenhower's infamous warning
about the military-industrial complex
Eisenhower the five-star general in
command of Allied forces in World War
two warned of his farewell address of an
arms industry that could one day warp us
policies for its own purposes he said in
the council's of government we must
guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence whether sought or
unsought by the military-industrial
complex the potential for the disastrous
rise of misplaced power exists and will
persist we must never let the weight of
this combination endanger our liberties
or democratic processes it seems then
that bot is the epitome of the dreaded
military-industrial complex in its quest
for profits Vaadin homeland or literally
create war for the purpose of selling
peace as home Lander explains he's
created a superpower terrorist to enable
a super-powered military does ever occur
to you that a soup terrorist showing up
exactly when we needed him to
pretty incredible coincidence it's
almost like someone planned it me it
made him here the show draws on real
life where governments often fabricate
threats to justify their own agenda but
in the face of supervillain terrorists
it's easy to forget that sometimes the
threat comes from the heroes themselves
caught in the paradoxical belief that an
arms race is the only way to be safe
it's no wonder the US has to bend at
BOTS demands again they've got no choice
frankly it doesn't even matter how the
enemy got the compound V what matters is
they've got it it is a whole new world
now and there is only one company that
has the product to fight back my company
my product but while money might explain
how bought manages to make superheroes
and politicians alike do its bidding it
doesn't really explain how it gets
society at large to go along with it
after all there are plenty of
billion-dollar corporations that
wouldn't be able to pay people to like
them Oh
Facebook huh so what gives well we think
it comes down to hero worship throughout
the entire first season we're
continually reminded how special heroes
are they're afforded special legal
protection enjoy unparalleled Fame and
get to attend some pretty cool parties
too in the words of superhero come
prophet Ezekiel superheroes are God's
gift to America why do we chosen
because of the Lord because we were born
with his power because we believe of
course you don't get to be special
unless everyone else is ordinary or as
the wise captain psycho once said we're
a different breed we shine with the
golden light of Providence but you
you've been helping these want people to
go against us it's a little surprise
then that this culture of hero worship
inevitably crushes our fellow mud people
Huey for example has no legal recourse
after a train kills his girlfriend and
even worse his dad doesn't even
understand what he's upset about Robins
service was nice
similarly all a a.style support group
exists for casualties of superhero
antics except all its members are so
indoctrinated in a culture of hero
worship that they make excuses for the
people that harm them as you can imagine
[Music]
it snapped off the crazy thing is I
still miss her it's like that's the cost
of a mortal like me for being with a god
like her according to philosopher
Christopher LeBron this cultural belief
system is wrapped up in what he calls
justifying minutes or the socially
accepted lies the dominators use to hide
their abuses of power after all it's a
lot easier to internalize your own
domination if you believe it's at the
hands of some divinely anointed
superheroes interestingly though the boy
seems to support the idea that if we
attack these justifying myths we might
actually stop the domination
specifically we see this interplay with
the character starlight originally
starlight believes that she was chosen
by God to save people but ever since she
joined the seven that seemed less and
less true her crime work was scripted
and most of her time was spent doing PR
tours and photo shoot until a religious
superhero rally made her questioned that
meant every single word that I say up
here I'm reading from a script'
I didn't write any of these words I
don't even know if I believe in them and
when Huey deals a death blow to that
myth telling starlight the truth of how
superheroes are made
starlight comes out a better person
she's not scared to fight back against
bots and rescue
Huy and the boys in the process why
because in place of that legitimizing
myth that enabled abuses of power
Charlotte is able to find her own moral
compass Hughie go or I'll say okay
copped so what do you think wisecrack is
the monopoly man really dominating us
and we're all just going along so we can
make a buck or are there other more
visible forms of domination we are
ignoring and if we call out this
domination if we break from the myth of
thinking it's okay well it really change
anything
well hit us up in the comments and let
us know what you think and before you go
I want to give one last shout out to
upstart upstart goes beyond traditional
lenders to give you a smarter interest
rate free yourself from the burden of
high interest credit card debt today by
checking your rate at upstart calm slash
wisecrack thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]